Jenna I understand that you started out
your career as a script reader at new
line did your research okay yeah you did
your research I'm impressed I sure did
it okay I was in graduate school at NYU
and I was totally surprised to figure
out that I had a knack for story and in
that I had a knack for giving notes and
so somebody told me you know you could
make money doing this there are people
who will pay you to read scripts and
books and give you your your opinions I
thought oh my god I can't believe I just
hit pay door somebody will pay me to
spell my opinions so I start to read
scripts around town and a variety of
places one of which was this tiny
company their offices were next door the
Port Authority in Times Square New York
which is really at the time grungy
kind of dangerous and there's really
eccentric people there and they had
released the John Waters movies and they
were all this kind of like hippies
running it and I loved it so so I
started to read scripts for them and
this lovely woman who was sort of
second-in-command at the company called
me in and her name was Sarah richer and
she said you know we've gotten so many
screenplays now submitted to us because
we've just produced a movie that's we're
finishing and word is out that you know
might be pretty good and so we're
getting a lot of scripts and I can't
handle them and I looked in the corner
there was a stack up to here it was
about to fall down and so I became the
first-ever
in-house reader I worked off the books
part-time a few days a week while I was
going to grad school and of course that
first film was released and it was
Nightmare on Elm Street the company's
New Line Cinema that was Sara rusher and
Bob Shaye and it was just a handful of
us who were working together next to the
Port Authority and it was a very
exciting time this was the late 80s and
what they used to call off Hollywood
movies were exploding and so I was very
fortunate for the
10 years to grow up at new life it was a
decade of tremendous personal and
professional growth for me and so I
remained at new line and grew as the
company grew and went from being a
freelance part-time off-the-books first
ever script reader to setting up their
first story department to being their
first director of acquisitions to
eventually becoming the senior VP of
production in the New York office Sara
and Bob and Mike De Luca we had all been
working together went out to the west
coast instead of the LA office and I
stayed home and was very committed to
New York independent films and the
creative economy of what was coming out
of New York and the culture and because
we were in New York City and we were
riding the subways unlike our peers who
were going from their cars to their
offices to their screening rooms we knew
that hip hop was happening we were there
on the street and was all around us and
so when Reggie Cullen came in with an
idea for a movie
he was straight out of college and he
had made a short film house party I knew
and my team knew this was it
and I remember that actually out a
magazine about hip hop to explain to
them this is a cultural trend this is
happening and and of course they
listened and we made house party and
that went on to be you know history and
it was a really exciting wonderful time
and Newland was such a creative place
and we were so encouraged Bob Shaye just
encouraged us to express ourselves and
explore and bring things to the table
and I was having
great time what did the cultural cues
then teach you about where youth or
let's say the 18 to 34 demographic was
at that time because I find that
fascinating here you were writing the
subway and you picked up on so much more
about the current culture than somebody
that was going right from their garage
into the garage of their work well I
think that's the big advantage of being
in New Yorker I am back in New York
full-time I was in LA for many years
actually raising my child I wasn't
working during the years that I was here
in LA I said look tangential but my son
of course is on the spectrum of autism
and LA is an epicenter for autism
treatments and so I this ended up being
a fantastic environment that was really
beneficial to him and so you know I
raised him for 10 years here but I'm
very happy to be back in New York
because it's a there's a vitality and
energy a democratic intermingling there
that I love and feeds me and you know
we're all New Yorkers first we all bump
up against each other we all ride the
subways together we'll or you know
elbowing into the deli to get our
morning coffee together there's a way
that the community of New York is larger
and ultimately really kind of unites us
and so of course there's divisions I
don't need to be romantic idiot
but there's just a way that there's a
kind of a natural multiculturalism in
New York that creates a lot of
interesting art mm-hmm going back to
your position at new line it sounds like
you almost created a job for yourself
was it was that already one that was
sort of a job description in kind of
your way yeah no I definitely did what
happened was that the company was a it
was a tiny skeletal structure and as the
company grew and its needs grew it
became clear that there were areas that
needed to be developed and
so I was very supportive in the
suggestions that I made you know to
became clear hey we really need to have
a story department and we need to have a
way to log these scripts and we need to
hire some freelance readers to work with
me
that they understood so and then when I
started to go around to film festivals
and look at movies and it became clear
hey you know we really need to just have
an area of acquisitions that's looking
in conjunction with the people who are
reading the scripts separately from them
and they understood because it's not
like I was making this stuff up I was
seeing other companies doing it and we
were all tumbling around together this
is the other part that was extremely
exciting this who was my peer group this
was a time that
Miramax that Bob and Harvey were forming
Miramax and there was I rejoice minute a
company called cynic calm and of course
is so many classics guys and there are a
lot of people who we were all sort of
been doing this together and going to
the festivals together and these were
the first years of the Sundance Film
Festival and watching what we were all
doing and you know being friendly
competitors sometimes not so friendly
but in it together really growing
something up and so I was picking up
Hughes and bringing information back to
the fold you know so then in hindsight
what do you think those four ten years
whatever it was taught you about the
business like you know it's sort of from
a broad view oh well absolutely
everything I knew nothing I knew nothing
when I started working at new line I was
you know in my early 20s I was a grad
student and I just liked stories I knew
nothing about the industry filmmaking
thinking about market shares and
audience and business and and it was a
very good discipline I think what it
taught me first and foremost is to be
accountable and responsible that as a
storyteller you can tell whatever story
you want but you have to know who you're
speaking to you have to know how is your
story offering something new and who
wants to hear it and then to
realistically assess how many of those
people want to hear this story and
budget accordingly as opposed to some
creative artistic entitlement you know
I've got a great vision and I should be
given money like from a de Medici you
know rather hey this
you're asking somebody to invest in a
business venture you're asking somebody
to give you a whole heck of a lot of
money to say something be responsible
for that be responsible to that and
assess it accurately and I think that
that's that kind of a paradigm of
reality based respectful consideration
of everybody's part that everybody is
working together it's not like the big
bad money guy and a mean distributor
everybody is the same goal to tell
stories and to share them with an
audience now how we all got to make that
work together and being mutually
respectful that everything's coming to
the table with the same goal different
points of view on it how can we the more
that you understand everybody's point of
view the better off everybody will be
and you'll be as a storyteller so for me
the fantastic discipline that we had
that was really unique was that a new
line unlike many other more
traditionally organized studios the the
production division wasn't isolated the
way it worked is that it was more like
we were functioning like independent
producers within the company here's how
so if I had a project that I was
passionate about like for example house
party I had to take the project to the
guy who's the head of marketing but I
was head of distribution the guy was
head of the ancillary media DBD at that
time VCR the guy's head of foreign and
say here's the project what's it worth
to you what's it worth to you what's
worth to you how can you sell it what do
you think the audience is bring it back
and see if that justified the budget and
then you go into a meeting with Bob and
say here's my numbers here's their
numbers does it make sense or not it was
very disciplined and I got to learn a
lot and think like they thought so is
that going to produce your school which
of course is incredibly important as a
filmmaker we don't exist in isolation I
am wildly against the prototype of the
indulged artist you know who sits on a
pedestal and is like a Pasha carried
forth you know no we're in this together
in a collaborative medium where it's
very important to understand
what everybody is doing why they're
doing it and work together so I think
that's the biggest thing that I learned
you know a healthy respect how can
someone know if they have ought or
entitlement syndrome because I think in
this day and age especially with the
wonderful term of the artist
entrepreneur and now so much of this is
in our own hands how do we check our own
egos and our own expectations I actually
think that artists entrepreneur causes
you to be disciplined because if you're
the one who's building it you're the one
who's raising money you're the one who's
going to find out right away whether
you've got story that other people want
to hear and you're the one who's gonna
realize hey five people want to hear it
I better bring my budget down so I think
that entrepreneur part of that moniker
is the most important antidote to the
utter entitlement the Ettore entitlement
presupposes the artist who's and a
pedestal preserved from right in this
kind of perfect bubble where they can
think and create you know so protected
from the sallying voice of the business
as opposed to the entrepreneur who is a
business person his saying I've got a
business venture and I'm gonna ask
people to invest in it and how am I
gonna express my art within a business
model that makes sense so I think that
is the antidote interesting you know I
hear you speak so much about business
and numbers and marketing but I also
hear that you have an emotional
intelligence that's very high as well
and I don't know if you've been told
that but but how do you bring that to
your work and how does that play out you
have a hole I'm first emotional IQ yeah
it was disciplining my emotional
emotionality and which was so helpful I
think as an artist we often work best
against limitations you know that that
some it's it's it's a whole idea that
when you're writing poetry to have to
discipline yourself to write the poetic
forms you know will then give you so
much more shape
you're doing more freeform that
limitations force us to refine and
define our vision and develop skill and
craft you know so here's the thing you
can be a crass person without being an
artist but you can't be an artist
without knowing your craft and so the
task of making art requires it demands
Aristotle talks about this in his
poetics it requires that we be right
brain and left brain as Aristotle talks
about it he talks about the madman and
the analytical mind that we have to you
know give ourselves over to being the
maniac you know who just feels and feels
and then we have to stop and look at it
and analyze and ask rigorous questions
of our work to give it that shape and
craft and I think that craft extends to
all of these aspects of reaching your
audience it's all part of the craft the
craft of physically producing the craft
of directing the craft of creating the
the beautiful glorious symmetrical
machine that is your movie your story
and then the craft of relating to
audience and now with this exciting
dynamic digital world direct fan
distribution speaking to audiences
crowd sourcing raising money from them
directly that's craft that's a
discipline that's knowing how to
organize your vision into something that
is clear to others so that they
participate with you and that's that's
prettiest and and requires that we are
emotional and analytical both you know
really need both if you're gonna make
art Janet I've heard you interviewed on
another show that was about autism and
you said something that's interesting
that applies in in so many aspects and
that is part of being a well-adjusted
adult is knowing what your limitations
are and and I think a lot of us
go into certain ideas of what we want or
or or chase after certain things yeah
and I'm wondering how do we weave that
into you know filmmaking I mean you work
at at Tisch and you deal with students
and we all have an idea of who we want
to be once we leave college we all have
a idea of who we want to be by 30 by 40
and so how do we reconcile what our
limitations are and knowing what our
strengths are and what they'll never be
because I think sometimes yeah that's
that's half the battle then knowing
where to direct your energy but there's
not an easy answer that one it's called
growing up it's a lifelong process of
you know in Buddhism there's an idea of
you know preferences what are we what
are we attaching to what is our
willfulness that's attaching to certain
preferences that is impeding our ability
to see what's in front of us today right
now and embrace it and I think that's
the task of being an integrated human
adult period full stop in all aspects
what's in front of you who are you in
relationship and and how are you showing
up for right here and now because past
is history future is fantasy it's right
here and now what's actually happening
as opposed to what I must make of it
what I must see what I require and
demand it to be what I am furiously
disappointed that it is not now when you
have a child with special needs you've
come crashing up against that right away
this is what's in front of you this is
who your child actually is are you going
to open your eyes to it accept and rise
to the challenge of who this actual
child is what this actual child really
needs what this person in front of you
not your idea your imposition your
fantasy or your disappointment your
frustration your rage no so when you're
a parent and you get the diagnosis that
your child is has autism you know the
brain is most plastic 0 2 H 3 continues
to be somewhat plastic till age 10
drop-off after that now we now know
happily brain is plastic till death but
there's a radical drop-off
okay so you get the diagnosis clock is
running meters ticking you can save your
child's life or you can have your
feelings about it that's not a choice so
you just have to accept you just have to
let that go let all that ego intention
and will and desire and preference go
and show up and that's a powerful
practice that's a powerful disciplines a
powerful practice and actually is what
allowed me to become an artist
I had self-sabotage 20s I felt insecure
and significant as a woman I didn't see
myself modeled or reflected as a
storyteller I didn't believe that I had
relevancy I didn't believe that I really
mattered for me to say anything and
after you go through the process of
raising a child with this level of need
I'll let dross burns away and Who I am
and my right to be Who I am
just became obvious and I didn't have to
struggle for it anymore I just was it
and I just stepped into that and that's
how I'm here now talking to you really
and now I happened to make Jaco two
hours and fly away the film before it
and and I hoped more you also did a
documentary I think about is one whose
producers did not direct where was one
of the producers a team of people that
made autism the musical that I'm very
proud of which aired on HBO and got two
Emmys and very proud of it and then
after that I wrote and directed my first
feature called fly away which is still
available in iTunes and Amazon which is
a very personal story about a mother
contending with her adult child I'm
sorry continue with her teenage child's
adult future and her child has autism
and because of that the producers of
Jacqueline red hearts saw that and
brought me the script and Lee came
together to collaborate and was really
great I was really lucky I was gonna ask
you who Jennifer Deaton
yes had you met her before okay
let me talk about how you were
introduced to her yeah so you know who
spent because it kind of goes back to
newline my boss and mentor a new line is
Sarah richer a wonderful woman
and she met Lucy Mukherjee an
independent producer who had joined
forces with Jennifer Deaton to produce
their passion project and Jennifer is
the aunt of a child with severe autism
and was inspired to write this story
Jack of the red hearts and they had no
backing no funding just a lot of Drive
and passion
Lucy met Sarah and Sarah said huh you're
looking for a director have you seen fly
away so she introduced them to my work
they approached me I read the script
thought it was you know excellent and
most importantly authentic we started to
collaborate together and then Lucy was
very fortunate to be introduced to a
company in New York Sun Dial Stefano
aqui and Joey Carey who are wonderful
guys they read the script overnight and
signed on and you know I think this is
important to say - there's so much
conversation and I'm a big participant
in the conversation about gender parity
and filmmaking it's incredibly important
this is a very important moment where we
as women step forward to tell our
stories but we can't do it alone and we
need men to help us and these guys
didn't even think about it
as a story by foreign about women they
read it as a human story gender-blind
they just responded to it without even
skipping a beat and we came together and
had a great experience making it it came
together very quickly we were so lucky
to get a brilliant cast and and I really
kind of a seamless collaboration and he
challenges making the film oh there's
challenges every day in making a film
making film is hard it's hard you're up
against the light you're up against you
know a prop that's not there you're up
against you know all of the human error
but you get through it and you pull
together and you know steady as she goes
I'm a real believer in calm steady
focused everybody is showing up to
problem-solve if you're spewing anxiety
and agitation that's only gonna make it
worse I know
I can't problem-solve somebody so angry
and agitated I can't be creative if
somebody is throwing that kind of static
my way so I'm not gonna throw it their
way you just keep it calm stay focused
you're gonna figure it out together and
by the way this is something I think is
also the advantage of having been you
know raised my child is that okay so
you're missing a key light that's not a
crisis a crisis is when your child is up
at 3 a.m.
having a raging tantrum and you haven't
slept for five weeks that's a crisis
this is just a problem this can get
solved okay so there we all were
tumbling around New York inventing and
clawing out the indie film movement and
so new line was in this kind of big loft
space right next to the Port Authority
and we actually had all of our films
there so we had the film transport
office in the back and there was this
kid who was the film inspector he was a
student at an NYU and he'd come after
school and would inspect all of the
film's to make sure that everything you
know was in the can and we started
talking I thought wow he's really smart
so at this point there are so many
scripts that I was reading I couldn't
handle it all and so I thought hey maybe
he'd be my first read help me up so he
started to read scripts for me this was
Ted Hope Wow
so Ted and I were just you know children
together now meantime I was meeting all
the young producers who had fire in
their belly and there was this guy he
was really smart and he come from
Stanford and he had this wide range of
appetite everything from you know
cartoons to high art he was just the
most generously democratic appreciator
and great taste and he was hungry to
produce so he started to read scripts
for me this was James Shamus and I was
talking to James about his tastes and
talking to Ted about his tastes and
realizing they had a lot in common so I
said I think you guys should meet you
should produce together so I introduced
them and they created a good machine so
this was an exciting time where this was
who was in
this is my peer group right we were all
figuring out together any parallels
between then and now in terms of any
type of the shift I think that you're
always finding groups of committed
ambitious young artists and film as a
collaborative medium so you're always
finding people who are exciting each
other igniting each other stimulating
each other and collaborating together
that is the nature of film nobody does
this on their own
nobody does this alone and so I see now
students coming out of NYU forming
collectives now the Internet is a
content creation machine so there's all
kinds of opportunities for students are
coming out of NYU were they've made
films together in class and now they
form production companies and they do
branded content that's essentially short
films that are showing their craft and
exercising their skills while they're
making that film that's going to be the
Sundance winner it's a really exciting
moment what are one of the number one
maybe fears or or sort of doubts in the
minds of a lot of the students that
you're talking to today well I think
that what everybody's concerned about is
that there's the tsunami wave of content
there's an overabundance of content and
how do you emerge I mean after you've
been making your YouTube videos what's
next now back in the 90s there was it
was a lot harder there were fewer
opportunities there was much less access
films were shot on celluloid
there were a handful of distributors
only one or two festivals that was
interested in indie films so it kind of
winnowed out a lot but it also meant
that if you did something of quality
there was a clear route and people would
see you whereas today would they find
you it's the same question people ask if
the Beatles you know put their music up
on Pandora or whatever would anybody
notice them and that's a real concern
how do people emerge and I
have any answer I mean I think it's
about this generation is gonna have to
figure it out that's what I say to my
students it's on you now you know we got
either this point you're gonna have to
form your own future and they will they
will